hey it's nice to meet you nice banana
outfit
thank you very much thank you very much
you know
i am obsessed with halloween
and costumes what is it like to work
in halloween and costumes every day
wayne
it is weird as hell
[Laughter]
yeah it is it's never it never stops
being odd seeing people
dressed up uh i'm around you but it also
helps me to appreciate
the creativity in people so that's the
cool part about watching them dress up
is the passion
i have learned a lot about game shows
on this game show week i was just such a
fan
there's definitely a science behind the
whole thing i i
look at my job um as a host
as a part ringmaster part traffic cop
and uh the part entertainer and part
therapist
and when when we have someone who comes
on the show
and they're so happy to be there and the
thing that we hear all the times when
someone goes
uh uh i can't make a oh this is
much harder here than when i'm at home
yelling at the tv
yeah it's much harder than when you're
there dressed as a banana
and i'm trying to get you to make a
decision and you know that this decision
depending on you know like let's be real
some sometimes it boils down to what's
in your bank account at home
this decision could alter
some people's circumstance and for some
people it's just fun so i have to gauge
them in the moment
where they're coming from talk them down
from the ledge
so that they can have the best time and
look the best that they can
so that when they're at home later
watching the show they aren't kicking
themselves because they felt that they
made a bad decision in the moment
oh that's my dog you know what
he agrees let's do this i'm
so excited to play let's play the big
deal
and i'm going to be the contestant and
i'll be playing to win prizes for one of
our vfs are you ready to meet her wayne
yes where's your vff melissa
hey melissa hey
melissa wayne wayne melissa
i love you guys so much it's the fox oh
my gosh
melissa tell us a little something about
yourself okay well i'm melissa valdez i
live in dallas texas
i am mommy to a 10 year old soccer
player and i
am single ready to flamingo
i love your flamingo costume okay and in
case anybody has been living under
a rock their entire life wayne tell us
how the game works
okay so we're gonna do the big deal of
the day we have three doors
door one door two door three you
at this point if we were doing let's
make a deal you you would have already
won
something else and you've made it to
this point in the show
it's really simple i'm gonna ask you to
make a decision
i want you to pick a door and you will
get whatever's behind that door
but let's say that i have a thousand
dollars
in my hand you can have this right now
and just
go and be happy or you pick your door
but it could be something worth
less than the one thousand dollars that
i have in my hand so
drew you have to make the decision do
you take this thousand dollars that
you're gonna share with your vff
a thousand dollars single flamingo out
on the town
or you choose door one door two or door
three
what are you gonna do well wayne i think
that i'm gonna be a total cliche because
when i'm watching at home i'm like stay
with what you've got you know what you
have
but now that i'm in the position i feel
like playing and being
maybe it's greedy maybe it's just
enthusiastic i'm gonna play wayne
okay we're going for it ladies and
gentlemen who's gonna go for it
go door one door two or door three
you're wrong you're on you got this
thank you melissa
for you i'm gonna pick door number three
okay door number three
all right so before we number three of
course which is your choice
let's show you door number two by the
way i have no idea what's behind these
doors just so everybody watching at home
thank you for joining us no clue
whatsoever
behind door number two
the bose lifestyle 650 home
entertainment system is a five speaker
luxury home theater system
this ultimate home entertainment system
by bose is valued at
nine hundred ninety nine dollars ninety
five cents
okay so drew you would have had the bose
entertainment system
over three grand over three grand it
would have looked
beautiful you could have used it netflix
and chilled all by yourself
or with another banana and a flamingo
let's take a look
number one
it's drew barrymore sings the berries
see drew barrymore
in a way she was never intended to be
seen singing a bunch of songs by
men named barry this 29 cd box set
features drew attempting hits by barry
manilow
barry gibb barry white and more
available now
only in this zonk
yeah yeah okay
so if you would have chosen door number
one you would have been zomb now on the
real show
we normally don't include zonks in the
big deal so this is actually a really
cool
twist i'm glad you avoided the zom so
there was the bose system
there was a zonk and now we're gonna
show you what's behind door number three
is it worth more than one thousand
dollars yeah
happy with this one two
door number three everyone in our
audience is getting a true medic magic
hands true shiatsu
neck and back massager with heat and
that's not all our vff contestant just
won the grand prize of ten
thousand dollars
[Applause]
oh my god i'm so relieved that was such
a good choice you've got 100
flamingo oh my god
melissa are you good with that drew
you're my bff and ten thousand dollars
oh my god
this is the best day ever
oh my gosh wayne thank you so much thank
you both so much this is incredible
all right well you're gonna win 10 000
but you know what else
we're gonna give you the bose home
entertainment system too
yeah yeah yes and vfs
i'm so excited for what you're gonna go
home with because a back and neck
massager
we tend to give away a ton of stuff on
this show which is really fun
but i'm jealous of this one